Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Chetan Doan. Ich bin heute der diensthabende Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Ist das für Sie in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich Doktor.
Bitte fragen Sie nach etwas nicht verstehen, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Warum fragen Sie noch mal? Ich habe schon alles bei der Anmeldung gegeben.
Ja, es ist sehr wichtig, die Daten zu bestätigen, damit wir Sie nicht mit anderen Patienten verwechseln.
Okay. Mein Name ist Dieter Kasmarek.
Dieter Kasmarek. Okay, könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
D, I, E, T, E, R.
Und das A oder E?
E wie erge oder A wie antum?
E wie Emil.
E wie Emil, Dieter. Okay.
D wie Ida, E wie Emil.
T wie Tedo, E wie Emil.
R wie Richard.
Okay, bitte Kasmarek.
K wie Kasmarek, A wie antum, Z M, A, R, E, K.
Okay, ganz nahmlich.
Herr Kasmarek, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am letzten Tag des Jahres 62.
62, wie schön. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
1,83 Meter.
Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
74,5 oder ich weiß es nicht.
Okay. Ja, Herr Kasmarek, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Meine Kumpels haben mich gezwungen hierher zu kommen.
Sie haben gesagt, es geht nicht mehr.
Ich habe Magenschmerzen, Herr Doktor, seit drei Wochen.
Seit drei Wochen Magenschmerzen.
Was meinen Sie mit Magen? Wo genau sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie mir zeigen?
Im Bauch, Oberbauch und um den Nabel.
Bauch und um den Nabel.
Ja.
Okay. Strahlen Sie Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Strahlen, was meinen Sie?
Ja, ich meine in anderen Körperregionen zum Beispiel, außer Ihres Baus, Strahlen Sie Schmerzen auf andere Körperregionen, in den Rücken, in die Schulter oder in den Unterbauch?
Ja, ja, Schmerzen sind in den Rücken manchmal im ganzen Bauch.
Okay.
Sind Sie Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten, Herr Kasmarek?
Ja, am Anfang, plötzlich aufgetreten, nach dem Fressen.
Sind Sie traurhaft oder verschwinden Sie seitweils?
Seit langer Zeit Schmerzen, aber in den letzten Wochen Schmerzen, kolikartig und dauerhaft.
Kolikartig und dauerhaft. Okay.
Was meinen Sie seit Langem? Seit wann haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt? Sie haben am Anfang gesagt seit drei Tagen.
Nein, nein, seit drei Wochen.
Seit drei Wochen, aber ähnliche Beschwerden, mein Bauchschmerzen dauert ca. drei Monate.
Aber das war leichter, die letzten drei Wochen war immer schlimmer geworden.
Okay, das habe ich verstanden. Im Laufe der Zeit sind Sie schlimmer geworden. Okay.
Entschuldigung. Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10? Wobei keine Schmerzen und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen bedeuten?
Die Schmerzen ca. ja jetzt 5.
5 und 10. Okay, das habe ich notiert. Gibt es einen Auslöser für Ihre Schmerzen? Zum Beispiel nach dem Essen oder ...
Nach dem Essen. Gestern Abend habe ich einen Eiersalat mit Brot und Butter gegeben.
Aber ich meine Auslöser. Sie haben schon gesagt, seit drei Wochen haben Sie diese Schmerzen. Vielleicht bis vor drei Wochen, meine ich.
Nach dem Essen. Ja, kann ich sagen. Deswegen trinke ich viel Alkohol und Bier. Aber das hat mir nicht geholfen.
Vorher, wenn ich trinke, geht es ein bisschen gut. Aber jetzt funktioniert es nicht. Herr Kaczmarek, Alkohol ist nicht ein Medikament.
Sie brauchen eine echte Lösung für Ihr Problem. Aber das hilft mir.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Aber wir versuchen heute eine echte Lösung für Ihre Schmerzen herauszufinden.
Okay, bitte machen Sie keine Sorge. Und ich würde gerne wissen, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder hindert?
Zum Beispiel Sie haben gesagt, nach dem Essen, Sie haben Ihre Schmerzen angefangen. Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt, außer Essen?
Ja, alles, was ich gegessen habe. Immer Essen. Wenn Sie essen, verstärken Sie sich die Schmerzen. Okay.
Herr Kaczmarek, haben Sie dagegen außer Alkohol Medikamente eingerommen?
Nein, keine Medikamente.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie seit drei Monaten diese Beschwerden haben. Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig.
Waren Sie deswegen schon einmal beim Arzt?
Ich habe keinen Hausarzt.
Ist das zum ersten Mal?
Ja, das ist das erste Mal. Seit zehn Jahren habe ich keinen Hausarzt. Und das erinnere ich mich nicht an.
Herr Kaczmarek, Sie sind 59 Jahre alt. Auch wenn Sie sich gesund fühlen, sollten Sie regelmäßig Ihren Hausarzt besuchen.
Dadurch können wir viele gesundheitliche Probleme früh erkennen und eine bestmögliche Behandlung planen und behandeln.
Deswegen ist das sehr wichtig, die Regelmäßigkeit.
Ich war gesund. Vorher hatte ich keine gesundheitliche Probleme. Deswegen bin ich nicht besucht.
Wie gesagt, auch wenn Sie sich gesund fühlen.
Haben Sie so drinnen einen sauren Ausstoß oder voller Gefühl?
Ja, alles habe ich.
Alle diese Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ja.
So notieren?
Ja, Übelkeit, Erbrüche.
Ich habe das danach nicht gefragt. Vielleicht auch Übelkeit und Erbrechen.
Seit wann haben Sie Übelkeit?
Drei Wochen.
Drei Tage war ein bisschen stark.
Das ist stärker geworden. Und wie sah das Erbrochene aus?
Ich habe immer ein bisschen gelb-lichtes Essen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Schlechtes.
Gibt es drin Blut?
So etwas habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ok, das habe ich auch notiert.
Herr Kasmarek, haben Sie Fieber, Stölzfuss, Nachtschweiß oder kalten Schweiß?
Manchmal habe ich Schwitzen.
Schwitzen Sie mehr als sonst?
Ja, natürlich.
In der letzten Zeit ist Nachtschweiß sehr stark und meine Kleidung ist durchgenäßt.
Durchgenäßt? Ok.
Das notiere ich mir.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Atemnot? Herzrasen?
Nein, Herzrasen habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Brustschmerzen und Atemnot?
Nicht so viel.
Weiß meinen Sie nicht so viel? Haben Sie?
Manchmal strahlen die Schmerzen ein bisschen aus.
Aber Sie sollten meine Fragen immer richtig antworten geben.
Das ist sehr wichtig, eine richtige Diagnose festzustellen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Meine Schmerzen sind im Bauch.
Ok.
Wir machen weiter. Die nächste Frage ist über Ihren Stuhlgang.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang?
Ja, wie gesagt, seit drei Wochen habe ich einen Durchfall.
Durchfall? Leiden Sie darunter? Ok.
Wie sah der Stuhl aus?
Perlbraun.
Ja, glänzend.
Ja, wichtig zu wissen.
Es riecht sehr schlecht.
Das ist auch wichtig für mich.
Und ein bisschen glänzt.
Ok. Ich würde gerne wissen, ob es Blut gibt.
Nicht gesehen.
Ok. Richtig zu wissen.
Was ist mit dem Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Oder haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, in der letzten Zeit beim Wasser, wie Altbier.
Altbier. Ok. Dunkel. Meinen Sie dunkel?
Ja, dunkel.
Ok. Dunkel als sonst.
Nicht rötlich, aber wie Altbier.
Ja.
Ok. Das ist auch wichtig zu wissen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Kaczmarek?
Ich habe keinen Appetit mehr, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, ca. 10 kg abgenommen.
In welchem Zeitraum haben Sie das abgenommen?
In der letzten Monate.
In einer Monate?
Ja, in einer.
Das ist wichtig zu wissen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, ich habe sehr starke Schmerzen und Durchfall.
Deswegen kann ich nicht so gut schlafen.
Es tut mir leid zu hören.
Es muss sehr schwer sein.
Herr Kaczmarek, gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Chronische Krankheiten, meine ich.
Oder wie Blutdruck oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Ja, wie gesagt habe ich in den letzten 10 Jahren nicht meine Pausen besucht.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen und deswegen möchte ich nicht wiederholen meine Empfehlungen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich hatte nur Hühneraugen am Fuß.
Ja, rechter Puls.
Wurden Sie deswegen operiert?
Warum haben Sie so viele Fragen?
Alle diese Fragen sind sehr wichtig für mich, um die richtige Diagnose festzustellen.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass Sie die beste Therapie haben.
Ich muss danach fragen.
Wir waren vor 30 Jahren wegen eines Autounfalls.
Warte und Scheinbahn.
Fixiert.
Okay.
Nach dem OP habe ich so viel Blut geblutet und dann 4 Blutkonsernen gegeben.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie das erleben mussten.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, Herr Kaczmarek?
Ich nehme morgens, mittags und abends in der Nacht Schlafs.
Wie gesagt und wiederholt ist Alkohol nicht Medikament.
Nehmen Sie echte Medikamente ein?
Ich frage.
Für mich ein Medikament, Herr Doktor.
Aber für uns ist das nicht.
Herr Kaczmarek, sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ja, bei mir gibt es eine Wasserallergie.
Wenn ich viel trinke, muss ich sehr oft häufig auf die Toilette gehen.
Aber es gibt keine bekannte Allergie oder keine bekannte Allergie, kann ich sagen.
Vielleicht weil Sie zu viel Alkohol konsumieren, nennen Sie oder nennen andere als Wasserallergie.
Meine Frau hat mir gesagt.
Haben Sie außer Wasserallergie oder leiden Sie unter anderen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
So weit ich weiß es nicht.
Herr Kaczmarek, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, eine Schachtelpackung.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Mit dem 17 Jahre, über 40 Jahre.
Herr Kaczmarek, ich vermute, dass Sie Alkohol trinken.
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Sie haben eben schon gesagt, dass Sie ein bisschen viel trinken.
Ich würde wissen die genaue Menge von Alkoholkonsum.
Nicht so viel, tagsüber vier Flaschen Bier und am Abend zwei Schnaps.
Okay, aus medizinischer Sicht ist es zu viel.
Aber vielleicht sprechen wir wieder darüber.
Wenn Sie mit Alkoholkonsum zu reduzieren oder aufzuhören, können wir dabei unterstützen.
Routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben, Herr Kaczmarek?
Ja, mit Cannabis.
Zwei oder drei Joint alle zwei, drei Wochen mit meinen Freundinnen.
Seit einem Jahr habe ich nicht mehr geraucht, weil ich keine Kohle habe.
Okay, ja freut mich, dass Sie damit aufzuhören, aufgehört haben.
Und ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause haben.
Seit fünf Jahren, ich bin arbeitslos, habe keine Arbeit, Stress, kann ich nicht arbeiten, leider.
Stress zu Hause?
Ja, ich bin alleine, deswegen habe ich kein Geld.
Sind Sie geschieden oder im Trainungsjahr?
Getrennt, nicht geschieden.
Okay, wichtig zu wissen.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo sie ist.
Sie haben keinen Kontakt?
Ja.
Und sind Ihre Eltern gesund oder leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater hat einen Diktam Krebs, er ist 86 Jahre alt und wohnt in einem Altenheim.
Altenheim, okay.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist verstorben.
Es tut mir leid für Ihren Verlust. Woran ist sie verstorben?
Sie hat Blutsturz, wissen Sie, was das ist?
Ja, natürlich.
Wahrscheinlich ist sie verstorben an einer betroffenen...
Sie hat viel Blut auf den Tests.
Blutverspuckt, das habe ich so verstanden.
Vielleicht hatte sie eine leberbetroffene Krankheit.
Ich kann so sagen.
Okay, Herr Kaczmarek, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und für Ihre Geduld.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht auf Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Nein, aber Herr Doktor wissen Sie, mein Opa hat wegen eines Magenkrebs verstorben.
Habe ich Krebs?
Ich kann nicht eine genaue Antwort geben.
Meine Mutter ist plötzlich gestorben.
Wie bitte?
Das habe ich auch notiert.
Wie gesagt, ich kann Ihnen keine genaue Antwort geben.
Aber wir werden alle notwendigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann können wir darüber widersprechen.
Und machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Sie sind in guten Händen und wir werden alle notwendigen Behandlungen machen.
Okay.
Okay, Doktor, vielen Dank.
Muss ich hierbleiben?
Ja, Sie sollten hierbleiben.
Zuerst bis zu den Ergebnissen.
Dann sprechen wir wieder darüber.
Okay, ob Sie hier weiterbleiben oder nicht.
Okay, Herr Doktor, vielen Dank. Ich warte auf Sie.
Ich werde zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Dann Ihnen etwas Blut abnehmen.
Danach einen EKG schreiben, um eine Herzursache auszuschließen.
Anschließend werde ich einen Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Bauchultraschall?
Ja.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, Herr Krasmarek, ein Ultraschall ist eine schmerzfreie und strahlenfreie Untersuchung.
Die etwa 15 Minuten dauert.
Damit können wir Ihre inneren Organen und Gefäßen gut beobachten und untersuchen.
Ja.
Danach, sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen, besprich ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Ich werde sagen, ob Sie hier bleiben müssen.
Okay, kann ich noch einen Beatricken?
Natürlich nicht. Die Ursache Ihres Beschwerden ist wahrscheinlich auch Alkoholkonsum.
Deswegen sollten Sie mit Alkohol aufhören.
Ich rate ab, dass Sie Alkohol trinken.
Okay.
Trink, trink.
Ja, Dr. Dorn am Apparat, bitte.
Guten Morgen, ich bin Frau Fischer.
Frau Bergheim, Kaliumwert 2,58 Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Oberarzt beobachten?
Entschuldigung, können Sie das wiederholen? 2,8.
2,58.
5,8, okay. Das habe ich so notiert.
Frau Bergheim.
Ja, die Name habe ich richtig.
Bergheim mit K.
Nicht Berg, okay. Wichtig zu wissen.
In der Mitte gibt es nicht K.
Okay.
Schönen Tag.
Danke für die Informationen. Ich leite es weiter. Danke.
Herzlich willkommen Herr Dr.
Hallo Frau Oberarztin.
Können Sie sich selbst vorstellen?
Ja, ich versuche. Gerne. Ich bin Dr. Dorn. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Benutzen Sie nicht. Ich versuche.
Natürlich, ja. Ich mache gerne.
Was mache ich gerne?
Es ist besser.
Mein Name ist Zeytin Dorn. Ich komme aus der Türkei. Ich bin 41 Jahre alt.
Ich lebe seit etwas mehr zweieinhalb Jahren in Deutschland.
Wir leben mit meinem, wir wohnen, ich wohne mit meiner Familie, ganzen Familien zusammen.
Ich bin verheiratet und habe zwei Söhne.
Und seitdem ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin, lerne ich intensiv Deutsch.
Ja, und jetzt bin ich für die Prüfung hier.
Bis ich nach Deutschland gekommen bin, habe ich in der Türkei als Arzt gearbeitet.
Seit ich denke zehn Jahre lang oder mehr als zehn Jahre lang als Arzt gearbeitet.
Ja, ich habe als Allgemeinarzt, Familienarzt und Assistentarzt zwei Jahre lang in der Pathologie Abteilung und etwa vier Jahre lang in der Innermedizin Abteilung.
Ich bin in Deutschland schon Facharzt.
Ja, theoretisch. Ich bin nicht Facharzt.
Aber ich habe fast sechsjährige Weiterbildungen in verschiedenen Abteilungen gemacht.
Ich habe meine Weiterbildung in Innermedizin nicht abgeschlossen.
Nicht abgeschlossen, ja.
Weil ich im Jahr 2017 meine Stelle an der Universität veranlassen musste, konnte ich nicht schaffen oder meine Weiterbildung abschließen.
Dann habe ich als Allgemeinarzt in verschiedenen Privatkrankhäusern gearbeitet.
Weil die Lebensbedingungen in der Türkei schwer geworden sind, habe ich eine Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Und jetzt bin ich hier und ich versuche ein neues Leben in Deutschland auszubauen.
Natürlich möchte ich in Deutschland als Arzt wieder arbeiten. Dazu bemühe ich mich immer.
Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Was denken Sie? Bemühe ich mich oder versuche ich mich?
Bemühe ist besser.
Versuche ich mich?
Ich denke nicht. Du arbeitest, du arbeitest.
Ich habe meinen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mitteilen.
Ich habe einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, dass Frau Bergheim einen Kaliumwert von 2,58 Millimol pro Liter hat.
Dieser Wert ist stark erniedrigt und entspricht Hypokalämie.
Ja, wir mögen Hypokalämie.
Ja, immerhin.
Und wir mögen auch Bergheim.
Bergheim.
Okay. Was ist die häufigste Ursache für Hypokalämie?
Ja, dazu gehören, ich meine die häufigsten Ursachen gehören, bei Hypokalämie erhöhte Renal Kaliumverlust.
Zum Beispiel durch Diuretika oder Hormonale wie Hyperoldestronismus oder Tüvulare Erkrankungen.
Außerdem könnten extra renale Verlust wie Durstfall, Erbeleidigung, diese können zu einer Hypokalämie führen.
Okay.
Die häufigsten Ursachen dazu.
Ich bin bei Hypokalämie.
Und?
Ich habe Symptome, ich bin bei Hypokalämie.
Ja, häufig erwarten wir dabei natürlich Muskelschwäche, Muskelkrämpfe, auch Parasithesien, Obstipation oder paralytische Ileus.
Und auch die gefährlichsten sind natürlich herzbetroffene Symptome der Hypokalämie.
Diese Herzlithmusstörungen, zum Beispiel extra systolen oder ventrikulare Tachycardin, kann ich oder würde ich sagen.
Oder die Pürifer, die Püriferin möchten hören.
Ja, wieder.
Kamma-Filiman.
Wir haben das gesagt.
Besonders Kamma-Filiman.
Wir können durch Defibrillation behandeln.
Das behandeln.
Ja.
Okay, was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Ja, Frau Oberarztin.
Wie gesagt, ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Es geht um Herrn Dieter Kaczmarek.
Er ist 59 Jahre alt, geboren 1.1.1962.
Er ist 1,83 Meter groß, wiegt 74,5 Kilo.
Herr Kaczmarek kam heute zu uns wegen seit drei Wochen bestehender Oberbauchschmerzen.
Laut Aussage des Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich postprandial nach dem Versehen von...
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Vor dem Essen aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen in den Rücken ausstrahlen.
Nach Angaben des Patienten sind die Schmerzen kolligartig.
Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 von 10 auf der NRS.
Außerdem erwähnt er, dass er seit drei Monaten ähnliche Beschwerden hat.
Die Schmerzen sind jedoch im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Begleitend klagt er über Übelkeit, Durchfall, Erbrüchen.
Außerdem hat er dunkle Urin und Nachtschwitzen.
Der Durchfall sieht hellbraun und gelernst aus.
Und wie gesagt ist der Urin dunkler. Bitte schön.
Sie können statt Schwitzen Nachtschweiß, weil der Patient gesagt hat, ich muss in der Nacht meine Kleidung wechseln.
Ja, das habe ich mich erinnert.
Was bedeutet Schmerz?
Das ist ein Befund der Exoklininsuffizienz der Pancreatitis.
Meinen Sie das?
Ja. Und auch vegetative Anamnese ergaben sich in Appetens eine Gewichtsabnahme von 10 kg innerhalb von ein Monaten.
Und die Sonne. Ansonsten ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Die Allergieanamnese ist unauffällig.
Medikamentanamnese ist auch so.
Und weil der Patient seit 10 Jahren keinen Arztbesuch hat, können wir eine medizinische Vorgeschichte des Patienten.
Er berichtet keine chronischen Erkrankungen.
Beim Patienten wurde vor 30 Jahren eine Osteosentäs Operation durchgeführt.
Er brauchte eine Bluttransfusion.
Warum wurde ihm eine Osteosentäs Operation durchgeführt?
Wegen eines Unfalls wurde der Patient operiert.
Sie müssen nicht. Ich möchte nur fragen.
Ich muss nicht die Vorstellung, aber wenn Sie es genau wissen, dann soll ich sagen.
Dann bekommen Sie diese unwichtigen Fragen.
Das habe ich verstanden. Danke für die Informationen.
Bei der Noxanamnese ist bei diesem Patienten sehr wichtig.
Er raucht seit 47 Jahren eine Schachtel Zigaretten und er trinkt viel Alkohol.
Er trinkt täglich vier Flaschen Bier und zwei oder drei Schnaps.
Bis vor einem Jahr hat er Cannabis zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche als Joint konsumiert.
Die Familie Noxanamnese gab einen Kolonkarzinom bei ihrem Vater.
Seine Mutter ist an Hermann Temes verstorben.
Sozialanamnistisch ist er getrennt und lebt allein.
Warum konnte seine Mutter eine Hermann Temes haben?
Wahrscheinlich hat sie eine Oesophagusvarytsin.
Vielleicht wegen möglicher Leberkrankheit.
Leberzirrhosis oder andere Leberbetroffene.
Was kann die Ursache sein für diese Krankheit?
Die häufigste in entwickelten Ländern ist viel Alkoholkonsum.
Der Vater oder die Großmutter hat auch Krebs.
Aber das habe ich nicht genau notiert.
Sozialanamnistisch ist er arbeitslos getrennt und lebt allein.
Er hat eine Tochter, aber keine Information über den Gesundheitszustand ihrer Tochter habe ich.
Weil er keinen Kontakt mit ihr hat.
Nach dem Anamnistischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf einen akuten Schub einer chronischen Pankreatitis.
Warum hat er einen akuten Schub einer chronischen Pankreatitis?
Er hat viel Alkoholkonsum und seit zehn Jahren keine Arztbesuche.
Er hat eine Gewichtsabnahme und in einer kurzen Zeit viel Gewichtsabnahme.
Alle Beschwerden oder alle Angaben sprechen dafür eine chronische Pankreatitis.
Seit wann hat er diese Beschwerden?
Seit drei Wochen hat er diese Beschwerden.
Am wichtigsten ist die Dauer.
Seit drei Monaten hat er eine Beschwerden und auch Stereotöre.
Wenn er in einer sehr hohen Gewichtsabnahme ist, dann sagen Sie diese Beschwerden.
Am wichtigsten ist die Dauer.
Welche Differenzialdiagnose kommen im Grunde?
Differenzialdiagnose, Pankreatiaskarzinom und eine Kolodekolidiasis.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, muss ich natürlich zunächst körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Anschließend werde ich Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Außerdem ist es wichtig, eine KG zu schreiben, um eine mögliche Herzursache oder Herzerkrankungen auszuschließen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich Greitörner...
Ich möchte diese Zeichen nicht nennen, weil ich danach Fragen bekommen habe.
Was erwarten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Oder voraufwarten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Wenn ich diese Frage nicht bekomme, soll ich nicht daran nennen.
Ich kann nicht gut ausführlich erklären, wie diese Zeichen sind oder wie es weitergeht.
Deswegen möchte ich sie nicht nennen.
Geht es auch in der Prüfung?
Natürlich, wenn du sehr gut wirst, musst du bei der Aufklärung nicht die Diagnostik erklären.
Wenn der Prüfer die Prüfer möchte, können Sie einfach fragen.
Ok, das habe ich verstanden.
Ich achte bei der körperlichen Untersuchung auf die Kühnzeichen, die Greitörner-Zeichen und auch eine globale oder eine Ikterus.
Ok, was bedeutet Greitörner und Kohlenseichen, Fox-Zeichen?
Diese Zeichen können wir besonders bei nekrotisiertem Pankratitis erwarten oder beobachten.
Diese Zeichen deuten auf Blutung hin, in Pankratitis.
Diese Zeichen sind auf die Farbveränderung.
Greitörner erwarten wir, die Lateral-Zeichen, Farbveränderung und andere.
Die Kühnzeichen sind im perimblikalen Bereich.
Die Fox-Zeichen sind im ingrinalen Bereich.
Wir erwarten diese Zeichen meistens bei nekrotisiertem Pankratitis.
Sie deuten auf Blutungen im Pankratitis.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild, Entzündungsparameter, Lipase, Amylase und auch Blutzucker, Hemoglobin-1, Elektrolyten, Herz- und Muskel-Enzyme,
Nieren- und Leberwerte, Cholestalsparameter und auch Lipidprofil sowie eine Stuhldiagnostik bestimmen lassen.
Was kontrollieren Sie im Stuhldiagnostik?
Ja, L-Astaseins-Enzyme kontrolliere ich im Stuhl.
Als eine Zeichen für Pankratitis oder indirekte Zeichen für den Patienten Pankratitis.
Des Weiteren werde ich eine Sonneabdome durchführen gegeben, besonders in diesem Fall.
Ich werde eine Sonneabdome durchführen und gegen einen Fall eine Sonneabdome veranlassen.
Was zeigt das Ultraschall uns bei chronischer Pankratitis?
Wie bitte?
Was zeigt?
Natürlich können wir in diesem Fall eine freie Flüssigkeit und peripherale,
ich meine um Speiseldürse oder um Pankratitis,
und können wir den Bauchultraschall beobachten.
Wenn es eine geilen Weg betroffenen Probleme gibt, können wir auch mit Ultraschall bestimmen.
Ja, Sie können sagen.
Verkalkung?
Natürlich Verkalkung können wir auch bestimmen.
Pseudokisten oder Pseudokisten.
Ja, ja, ich habe vergessen.
Auch wie gesagt ist es sehr wichtig gegebenenfalls einen CT-Abdomen durchzuführen lassen.
Und natürlich werde ich zudem ein gastroenterologisches sowie ein chirurgisches Konsil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich diesen Patienten intensiv stationär aufnehmen.
Weil Pankratitis ein lebensbedrohliches Krankheit ist.
Besonders die akuten Schuben chronischer Pankratitis.
Aber natürlich möchte ich nicht die Intensivstation Kriterien sprechen.
Als Initialtherapie empfehle ich Intensivstationär oder Flüssigkeit zuvor.
Elektrolytsubstitution meine ich Infusiontherapie.
Gegebenenfalls Nahrungskarenz ist in solchen Patienten wichtig.
Aber je nachdem die Beteiligungsparameter oder Stabilität des Patienten können wir darüber entscheiden.
Aber Nikotin und Alkoholkarenz ist bestimmt wichtig.
Ganz wichtig.
Als symptomatische Therapie empfehle ich Antimethikum, Analgetikum und Spasmolythikum.
Weil gegebenenfalls Spasmolythikum.
Und auch aus medizinischer Sicht ist es auch wichtig gegebenenfalls ein Antibiotikum.
Besonders bei nekrotisierten Pankratitis.
Und der PPI oder Protonpomper Hämmer ist auch wichtig.
Darüber hinaus würde ich auch gegebenenfalls Vitaminpräparate und Enzymkonzentrat oder wie kann man sagen.
Ich habe vergessen.
Enzymkonzentrat oder Ersatzung oder Ersatztherapie können wir auch verordnen.
Wenn ein Patient braucht, können wir Enzym-Ersatztherapie und Vitamin.
Ersatztherapie, Enzym-Ersatztherapie.
Nicht konzentriert.
Ok. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hier.
In diesem Fall wird es nach dem Test an der Akutpankratik ausgeführt.
Ist das bekannt? Oder muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen?
Wenn das Fall so ausgeführt wird, dann muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen.
Aber das Fall hat sich seit einem Jahr nicht so ausgeführt.
Vor allem seit einem Jahr.
Es hat sich seit drei Wochen oder drei Tagen so ausgeführt.
Die Zeit ist wichtig.
Die Zeit, die die beiden Fakten einander beitragen.
Die verschiedenen Spezies verändern sich auch.
Die sozialen Anamnestie spielen wie Papaz.
Oder ein Mann, der Musik allein spielt, arbeitet in Barren.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor.
Wir warten nicht auf die Akutpankratik.
Das wisst ihr besser.
Aber wenn man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnet, sagt man das in Glands.
Aber dann muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen.
Wenn man die Zeit von Hapensee, Hattensee, Shonfuree bezeichnet, sagt man das als Drei Wochen.
Daher muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen.
Das habe ich von Erfarung und Danish verstanden.
Aber wenn man schon seit drei Monaten, oder mehr, diese Schreie hat,
dann muss man das als heute gespielt haben.
Wenn ich das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen würde,
dann muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen.
Was ist das Risikofaktor, dass Papaz ist?
Da reden sie von den religiösen Szenen.
Wenn man die Zeit von Hapensee, Hattensee, Shonfuree bezeichnet,
dann muss man das als Akutpankratik bezeichnen.
Das ist das, was ich in der Arbeit mache.
Wenn jemand Musik auf der Strecke spielt,
dann ist das das, was ich in der Arbeit mache.
Das ist das.
Ich habe das nicht gewusst.
Ich denke, das ist so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das so machen.
Die Formen des Spiels sind so, wie es in den Noten steht.
Das ist nicht mein Bild, aber das, was ich einmal gesungen habe,
die Vakate, die Enden, die Veränderungen,
die Vakate sind so, wie es in den Enden gesungen ist.
Ich habe das vor einigen Jahren gehört,
dass das Akutpankratik nicht so ist,
wie es in den Enden gesungen ist.
Danke, Herr Hache.
Das ist so.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass es seit einem Jahr nicht sein wird.
Es ist nicht so, dass es seit einem Jahr nicht sein wird.
Das ist so.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass es nicht sein wird.
Das Beste ist die Zeit.
Ich kann dir noch eine Frage stellen.
Ja, bitte.
Ich wollte eine Testkarte.
Ich war 26 Jahre alt, aber ich war nicht zurück.
Ich wollte noch eine.
Ich war noch nicht zurück.
Ich wollte eine Testkarte seit 15 Mai.
Vielleicht 15, 20 oder 1 Jahr später.
Vielleicht 15. Mai.
Deswegen bin ich in Mahataya.
Ich möchte eine Simulation machen.
Oder ich kann noch etwas warten.
Ich muss die Anzeige anstecken.
Oder ich kann noch eine.
Es ist gut, wenn du früh anfängst.
Es ist nicht genug, nur eine Simulation zu machen.
Du musst eine Simulation-Frau finden.
Wir haben es auch mit den Kollegen gesagt.
Sie versuchen es auch in sich.
Sie machen es hier und dann geht es weiter.
Ich bin ein Japaner Freund.
Wir arbeiten jetzt.
Wir werden die Probe in 10 Tagen machen.
Es wird in 10, 15, 16 Stunden fertig.
Das ist das Beste.
Die Simulationen?
Ja.
Je früher du anfängst, desto besser.
Ja, danke.
Du kannst auch früh anfangen.
Du kannst dich besser fühlen.
Du kannst dich früher wieder erlauben.
Das ist gut.
Du kannst dich besser fühlen.
Du kannst auch die Simulationen in den Gruppen schreiben.
Die Simulationen machen die Anzeige.
Danke.
Es sieht nicht aus.
Ich kann meine Erfahrung über diese Begriffe
in meinem eigenen Arbeitsverfahren erzählen.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich in Düsseldorf
in der Zeit von 5-6 Jahren eine solche Begriffe hatte.
Alle erinnern sich an sich.
Es gibt keine Anzeige.
Die Begriffe sind alle gleich.
Es kommt mit dem Schmerz.
Wenn es mit dem Schmerz kommt,
dann ist es wie immer.
Wir finden die Begriffe.
Das Gastrointestinal System.
Wir haben schon bestimmte Fragen.
Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Stürgank,
Wasalasen-Sorgen.
Wenn es um diese Fragen geht,
dann bezeichnet man sie.
Wenn es um Kustum geht,
dann bezeichnet man es.
Wenn es um Stürgank geht,
Wenn es umiefen geht,
dann bezeichnet man es.
Wenn es umcro溉 geht,
Fibers, Stülpfros, Nahrschweiß, Kaisersweiß, Ausbrühe,
wenn wir über die Vakadevenamnese gehen,
Inapathens, Gewichtferanderung, Schlagstörungen,
Herz- und Lungengel,
wir haben die Zygason-Entestnassistin schon gefragt,
so ist das alles fertig.
Dann,
In den weiteren Fragen der Patientin
gibt es keine speziellen Fragen,
die immer klassisch sind,
aber es gibt sehr viele Reaktionen,
da können wir darüber sprechen.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an andere spezielle Fragen.
In den Reaktionen,
am Anfang sagt er schon, dass er es gegeben hat,
warum du es wieder fragst,
wie Ekrem abe so eine Reaktion gemacht hat,
diese Fragen sind für mich sehr wichtig,
damit sie mit anderen Patienten
mit gleichem Namen und gleichem Alter
nicht verwechseln,
die du sagen kannst,
um andere Patienten mit dem selben Alter
und dem selben Namen nicht zu verbrechen.
Und du sagst, dass diese Fragen wichtig sind für mich.
Und dann,
ich bin seit Jahren nicht mehr in die Hausarztin
und es ist gut zu hören,
dass sie gesund sind,
aber trotzdem sollen sie regelmäßig
ihre Hausarztin besuchen,
damit manche Krankheiten
und Zufrühe erkannt werden kann.
Es ist gut, dass sie gesund sind.
Es ist wichtig,
dass sie zuerst so empathisch sind.
Aber es ist wichtig,
dass sie regelmäßig ihre Hausarztin besuchen,
damit man sie früh erkennt.
Hier habe ich so etwas gesagt.
Dann,
wenn du die Patienten mit dem selben Alter
mit der Krankheit beantwortest,
dann ist es nicht so,
dass du sie mit dem selben Alter
mit der Krankheit besuchen kannst.
Das ist nicht so.
Ich habe ein bisschen mit dem selben Alter
mit der Krankheit verbreitet.
Ich habe es dann auch gemerkt,
dass ich mit dem selben Alter
mit der Krankheit be barbecue.
Er Half-Heft- hat mich get progressed,
deutي eigentlich wohl aufs Kšt.
Wir filmen die Patienten nicht so ist
ITEn wir sie mit den Patienten umliegen.
Wir sagen dann, sie tilesämten doesnh smiles.
Wir sagen, sie tageln rein.
Duonten L keine lüge.
Ich sage dann, sie tagen veel.
Daher diesen Witz learnen,
dasnehme ich bei.
Dabei gibt es sonst noch immer
Es ist nicht so, dass man alles so machen kann.
Wenn so ein Arzt kommt, dann sollte man nicht alles so machen.
Das ist nicht so schön.
Da haben wir schon gesagt,
Schnapp ist ein Medikament.
Da können wir das hier fragen.
Er sagt, dass er Alkohol trinkt und das als Medikament nutzt.
Denkt euch mal, dass er viel nutzt.
Es ist eine Reaktion, zu fragen.
Und dann können wir hier die Alkohol-Anamnesen nehmen.
Es ist kein Problem.
Ich denke, es ist sehr schön, hier zu machen.
Wir können hier fragen, wie viel Schnapp trinkt.
Trinken sie auf andere Alkohol-Anhalte,
die wir hier haben.
Dann können wir sagen,
dass es aus Medizin herrscht,
dass der Alkohol-Konsum so viel ist.
Und dieser Alkohol-Konsum kann die Ursache
in der Hand nehmen.
Das ist ein Versuch, mit dem Alkohol aufzuhören.
Es geht darum, zu sagen,
dass das nicht endet, das ist meine Leben,
das ich das verletze.
Das ist ein Versuch, das nicht endet.
Das kann man hier sagen.
Das kann man hier sagen,
wenn man als Medikament sagt.
Dann kann man sagen,
wenn man eine Allergie fragt,
dass man eine Allergie hat,
dann muss man nicht so viele Reaktionen
vergeben, wie man es hier sieht.
Die Ausführungen in der Hand sind eine Reaktion.
Die, die man versteht,
die die Anleitung der Stimme nicht beachten.
Die Anleitung in der Hand,
die Gesture, die Mimie.
Es gibt keine Allergie.
Das ist genug zu sagen.
Aber meine Freunde sagen,
dass ich so und so bin.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich wegen des Alkoholkonsums.
Ich trinke nicht so viel.
Das ist professionell,
so ist es professionell.
Wenn man das direkt aus der Stimme sagt,
dann ist es besser, das zu beachten.
Wie normal es ist,
dann ist es gut.
Ich kann es mir spontan sagen,
dass es mir einfacher ist.
Wenn ich mir die Schrift vorstelle,
dann ist es langsam.
Ich habe es gesagt,
dass ich eine andere Medikamente habe.
Das ist ein Scherz.
Ist das so?
Ist es eine andere Medikament, als Schnapps?
Ich habe mich ein bisschen gefühlt.
Das ist nicht wichtig.
Wenn man sieht, dass es eine Schnapps ist,
dann ist es kein Problem.
Das ist nicht so.
Man kann es sich so fragen.
Das ist kein Problem.
Wenn man sich mit dem Schnapps aus der Stimme
verabschiedet,
dann kann es so sein.
Es kann auch ein Problem sein.
So ist es mit der Allergie.
Sie haben recht.
Ich habe viele Fragen gestellt.
Aber das ist nicht wichtig für mich.
Ich muss die Patienten verantworten.
Wir fragen uns viele Fragen.
Man wird immer aufgeregt.
Man hat viele Fragen.
Too much Simulation.
Was ist ein Schnapps?
Das ist ein Schnapps.
Wir sein nicht Totes zwei,
indem wir regeln.
Wir machen eineushiable Führung.
in der Begegnung.
Ich will đi magnesium mit!
Das ist nachvollziehend?
Ja, ich kann iransch gut nachvollziehend.
Okay.
Ich fühle mich wirklich von meinem Herzen.
Das ist nicht eine sehr nette Bezeichnung.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich das nicht richtig verstehe.
Es ist wichtig, dass man die Bezeichnung immer wieder vermittelt.
Das ist wichtig.
Das ist verständlich.
Ich kann sehr gut nachvollziehend.
Das ist ein bisschen so.
Das ist wichtig, wenn man ein paar verschiedene Bezeichnungen hat.
Man muss es vielleicht ein paar Mal sagen.
Das kann man gut bezeichnen.
Wie mein Herr Cetin sagte.
Ich bin hier zu dem Patienten.
Ich habe in der Zeitung von Tainz-Zwei eine chronische Pankreatitis.
Ich möchte eine Differenz von Pankreatik und Cholidokalitias.
Ich werde die Versuchung weiterentwickeln.
Ich werde die Körperversuchung vornehmen.
Ich werde die Dividalparameter überprüfen und Blutfüder abnehmen.
Ich werde die Blutbild- und Tündungparameter überprüfen.
Ich werde die Nieren, die Elektronik, die Amylase, die Lipase, die Cholestase.
Ich werde die Stülldiagnostik, besonders die Stüll-Elastase 1, überprüfen.
Ich werde die Übungsstatus überprüfen.
Ich werde die Abdomen-Synographie, die Übungsstatus und die Stülldiagnostik überprüfen.
Ich werde die Abdomen-Thomographie überprüfen.
Ich werde eine Konsul-Innteilung für Gastroenterologie, gegebenenfalls Chirurgie, anfordern.
Sollte sich meine Verdacht-Diagnose bestätigen.
Ich werde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Die Patienten sollen eine Flüssigkeit zuführen, eine Elektrolitsubstation und als Symptomatik wie Analgetik, Antiemetik, Spasmalität, Protonpompehemma erhalten.
Und Leichkosten wird entfohlen.
Im Moment ist es immer nur Narungs-Karantäne, wenn man Pankreas-Karantäne hat.
Aber wenn man in einer sehr schweren Situation ist, wenn man in eine Situation ist, dass man nicht in die Zürich-Karantäne geht,
ist das so, dass man Pankreas-Karantäne aufnehmen kann.
Aber in der letzten Zeit war es nur Narungs-Karantäne, um eine leichtere Diät zu machen.
Aber es wurde so, dass man nicht auf die Oral-Besetzung geht.
Leichtkosten, also ein leichtes Öhen wird entfohlen oder verordnet.
Das wird dann ausgeführt.
Ich kann nach Folgenden nicht so genannt werden.
Es wird nur für Situationen genannt.
Man kann nicht so genannt werden, wie man sich an den Ferschlägen erkennt.
Ich kann nicht so genannt werden, wie man sich an den Ferschlägen erkennt.
Ich möchte noch etwas fragen.
Wie lange ist Nesiba-Hilfe?